hello everyone here we have another
amazing game from the London chess
classic round seven the game is played
between Magnus Carlsen and the Michael
Adams and it perfectly illustrates just
how much work one has to put in into
bringing down the world champion so far
they played a lot of games but the the
the score is a lot in the cousins favor
Costin won 10 games and the Adams won
only one game played in 2010 in the
Chess Olympiad and they drew six games
so you know it's a it's a pretty big
deal for Michael Adams but as Michael
Adams says he has a pretty bad score
against everyone in this tournament so
it's not it's not a really big deal you
know it won't affect his game so let's
see the game crossing has the white
pieces and he plays F for the birds
opening we have d5 the Dutch variation
of the bird Knight to f3 Knight to f6 g3
now g6 Bishop to g2 and the Bishop to g7
call sand castles I promise Castle we
have d3 c5 c3 Knight to c6 and night to
a3 rook to e8 knife to h4 b6 now II for
D captures on e4 and here you could
probably play D captures on e4 but then
the Queen's are getting traded off and
the costum doesn't want to go for this
cross someplace Queen to a4 and here
again you could play something like
let's say Bishop to d7 and then after D
captures on e4 it's a pretty it's a
pretty cool position but after Queen to
a four this is move 11 and here Michael
Adams really goes it really goes for it
he plays Queen captures on d3 so he
grabbed two points and is given up the
knight on c6 and you do have to capture
the knight Carlsen captures it and now
Bishop to d7 and you don't really have a
lot of squares for the Queen Carson
played the Queen to c7 and Knight the g4
by Adams and in this position
in this position rook to e1 was played
and the move that the move that Carson
was really afraid of here was rook a to
c8 Adams didn't go for this but Carson
said in an interview later after this
game that have to rotate the c8 and
Queen captures an a7 that the Queen was
to displace from the game and that black
had a lot a lot of active options here
with Bishop to b4 check let's say C
captures Queen captures and it would be
it would be very hard for white to
defend this in a practical game for
example there should be three Knight
captures you can't capture King to h1
it's it's cousin says that if Adams go
went for this that he probably would
have won the game but instead after this
Queen to c7 and Knight to g4 we have
rook to e1 and now Bishop the d4 check
immediately without first rook a to c8
displacing the Queen
so pawn captures Bishop Queen captures
would check Bishop to e3 Knight captures
and now Queen Queen to e5 and here
Carlsen can offer a trade of Queens so
that other variation we just showed
isn't possible we have f5 here and here
is a very very nice move Carlsen missed
a letter in an interview he said that he
checked it once but he didn't really he
didn't really see what was going on he
just checked one line but he didn't
check the other line
Carson played Bishop to h3 the move
cross and missed was
Knight to f3 and what happens here well
if you capture the night he captures on
f3 it's very simple you play Bishop
captures on f3 now first attacking the
rook and also now your knight is
attacked here and after something like
Queen captures on e5 or even night to
see to check out Queen captures on d4
Knight captures on d4 simply capturing
Bishop captures on a8 rook captures on
a8 and
this is this is a lot better for for
Carlson so this is a very nice move
constant mist
so after this f5 move constant didn't go
for Knight to f3 if you went for Bishop
to h3 and all night to see to check
Queen captures and Knight captures and
here cross and could have gone for for
some other moves here for example b4 is
an idea rook a to see one is an idea but
Carson said that although he is up a
piece look at this beautiful pawn chain
black has and the double e pawn is ready
to march forward and break up whatever's
left of course and spawns so instead of
any peaceful move cost and decided to
play rook captures on e4 and captures
any foreign out Bishop captures on d7 we
have rook to dat Bishop to a4 e 5 now
rook to e1 e captures on f/4g captures
on f4 and a six a bishop all the way to
d1 b5 here by Adams Knight the b1 and
the Carson said in this position that he
was he was pretty sure that he was gonna
lose I mean if if Adams played the the
correct moves and this was probably
Adams did have the opportunity to win
the game before even entering the
endgame like you've seen with that rook
a to c8 but even now he has to find one
move in this position Adams played
Knight to f5 and when Carson saw this he
says he was so relieved the move Adam
Smith is actually okay I'll give it five
seconds so it's a good exercise for you
to pause the video and find the nice
move for black it's a pretty long
variation actually the move the move
Animus missed was III and here's the
problem if you play rook captures on e3
now you get Knight to f5 and now your
knight and h4 is attacked the rook and
e3 is attacked and this opened up an
attack from the roof to the bishop on d1
so after something like Bishop to b3
check c4 Knight captures on f5 first C
captures on beef the
now your knight is attacked and also you
have threatening the be captures on a -
so after Knight to e7 check King to f8
now Knight to c3
here comes B for kicking away the night
I mean you can't move the knight if you
allow me captors on a - you're losing
the game so after a capture some b3b
captures on c3 and B captures on c3 now
these rooks are completely dominant and
here Carlsen wouldn't stand any chance
with white
so after this III move Adams missed
something like Knight to c3 would have
to be played and then rook to e8 Knights
- G - and now E - and this is the beauty
of it
Bishop captures Knight captures rook
captures rook captures and Knight
captures and Carson would have two
knives for the rock but rook to d8 and
the Knights are the Knights are useless
here this rook is coming to d2 and will
gobble up the a and B pawn and the black
is winning this game easily so this is a
Carson saw this Adam Smith this
unfortunately for Adams so after night
to be won Adams played Knight to f5 and
Carson immediately played Knight
captures G captures on f5 and King to F
- and although black is still better
here at least now Carson got you know a
small lease on life King to f7 Bishop to
e2 rook to d6 h4 c4 and a for now and
although black might still be better
here calls and said that he knew exactly
how Adams felt you know he had a winning
position twice and then he missed it and
then little by little you know Carlson
is I mean I mean Carlson is a better
player in general and also a better end
game player so it's natural that every
move they go deeper into the endgame
Carson will improve his position a
little by little and eventually
equalized and eventually get an
advantage so Adams kind of knew this
rook the c8 now eight capture some b5 a
capture some be 592 a3
now going for the b4 b5 pawn
rock to d5 rook c1 rugby to c5 Knight to
c2 now rook a8 we have nine three three
rook a to c8 back h5 now King to e6 h 6
King to f6 and now rook to a one so if
the King goes for the pawn king g6 then
rotate six check all as well be for now
roof to a sex check King to e7 row to a
seven check came to f6 and now kink the
e1 by Carlsen
it's not a good idea to play rook
captures on h7 c3 would come B captors
and c3b captures on c3 and the bishop to
D 1 C 2 now Knight captures rook
captures Bishop captures rook captures
with the check and after King G 3 check
King g2 and now King to g6
the H bomb is lost rook check King
captures and so it's own in position for
black at least maybe Carlsen could
muster up some way to draw it but
definitely not good for him so after
King to f6 King to e1 b3 now rook the b7
now going for rook to be for the
pressure the c4 pawn king to e6 rook to
b6 check King e7 looked before now rook
8 to c6 going for the h6 pawn bishop
captures on c4 rook captures on h6 and
rook captures on B 3 and now Carlson is
just better here and it's simply a
matter of time King to d8 rook to b8
check King c7 Rock to f8 now pressuring
the f5 pawn rook to h3 Knight to d5 with
check came to b7 rook to f7 check King
goes to b8 now b3 rook to h2 and now
Knight the b4 and here Carson is
threatening night to a6 for King the
king and the rook
but he also plants a little trick that
he was hoping that Adams walks into it
because it really makes it easier for
him to finish this game
King tc8 was played and now comes knife
to a six anyway attacking the rook you
can go to c7 so rook the c6 and now
comes rope to f8 with check and now as
you can see the knight is blocking this
square rook of course covers these
squares and wherever you go if you go
b7 or d7 the bishop will either pin the
rook with beef Bishop b5 or Bishop b5 so
kinkabe 7 was played now Bishop to d7
pinning the rook King captures the
Bishop captures King to b6 and after
Bishop to d7 the bishop will now capture
the f5 pawn it's a game over Adam says
Adams is simply a piece down and in this
position Michael Adams resigned the game
so yeah a very very poetic game if if
anything I mean it's what happens when
you played the world champion you know
you have a you you can win twice in the
position but if you don't do it then
you're not gonna win you're not even
gonna draw you're you're gonna lose the
game and it's a pretty good pretty good
victory for Magnus Carlsen yesterday he
pulled the pull of the Dragons Nakamura
and today a victory against Michael
Adams from a twice losing position so
he's definitely still in the race for
the first place tomorrow I believe he
faces nepo and he doesn't have that
great of a score against Knepper in
classical time format but he has the
white pieces and if he wants to win won
the chess classic he has to he has to
win so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it
unfortunately Michael Adams didn't as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon